done in this Nature Reserve awakened by
a collective cry
the hooded cranes sleep in these Coastal
mud flats rich with nutrients and far
from the reach of predators
in the past 10 Winters more have come to
this UNESCO biosphere Reserve to rest
and recharge before mating in the spring
in Russia Siberia and remote parts of
China by late November nearly 10 000 of
the estimated 15 000 in the wild were
spending the winter in sunchan double
that of the previous season
thanks to years of conservation efforts
and Farmers lending their plots these
red patched Birds marked as vulnerable
are on demand making for a crowd when it
comes time to eat
the reason why so many hooded cranes
have come to Sunshine Bay can be found
in the people's interest and the more I
study the issue it becomes clear that
preservation requires the attention of
the world
the community
filling up its sleeves to make this
habitat for
the healthy stay rice grains is
distributed and there's no groundwater
Illuminating a key factor in the spread
of the Avian Influenza virus
in what has been a fierce season of the
bird flu in Japan a record caseload some
in pools of water has led to a culling
of more than 10 million birds at poultry
farms in Izumi a topwintering site more
than 1200 hooded cranes were found dead
clearing out obstructions Community
leaders say artificial habitats such as
these while not ideal must be replicated
as habitat loss threatens hard-fought
progress the mayor of sunshine a town
that removed hundreds of electric poles
and wires when the flying birds got
caught in them says prosperity and
ecology must work together
when you observe sunchon Bay's
preservation story you realize how
useful it was for the city's development
it helped us move into the future
ecology leads economic growth
as this town calls for a change from
business as usual migrating birds just
want to fly as they have for Millennia
you know Kim Al Jazeera Sunshine South
Korea